the following line passes through the
point five comma eight and the line the
equation of the line is y is equal to
seventeen thirds 17 13
x plus b
what is the value of the y-intercept b
so we know that this point this x and y
value must satisfy this equation so we
know
we know that when x is equal to 5
y is equal to 8. so we can say
we can say so when x is equal to 5 y is
equal to
y is equal to 8 so we could say 8 must
be equal to
17 over 13 times x
times 5
plus b and then we can solve for b
so this if we simplify this a little bit
we get 8
is equal to
see 5 times 17 is 50 plus 35 is 85
is 85 over 13
plus b then to solve for b we just
subtract 85 over 13 from both sides
so we have 8
8 minus 85 over 13
85 over 13
is equal to b
and now we just have to add these two or
subtract these two numbers so eight is
the same thing as let's see 80
plus 24
is 104 so it is 104
over 13 this is the same thing as 8
minus 85 over 13
which is going to be let's see this is
19 over 13 is that right yes this is 105
then it would be 20 over 13 so this is
19 over 13. so it's equal to 19 over 13
which is equal to b so the equation of
this line is going to be y is equal to
17 13 x
plus
over 13.